[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
all right and we are live again
lord cognito here i love podcast lords
of gaming.net the amazing lady daddy and
pax how are we doing i'm doing great i'm
so excited to be able to talk about
fandom okay phantom okay now this is the
one i was really excited for have my eye
on it again for people who don't know
anything about phantom game telling
people what this is about so phantom
brigade is a cinematic turn-based mech
strategy game
and what makes it really unique is i
think a lot of
turn-based strategy games usually do
like you go the enemy goes you go the
enemy goes so it's kind of like chess uh
what phantom brigade does is you plan
out your movement at the same time as
the enemy and then everything plays
let me stop you right there
that was literally the reason why i
booked this place
as a as a term-based veteran that is
something i rarely see at all because
like you said it's always that chess you
go i go but what was interesting about
this that the simultaneous and then
seeing it unfold in real time was very
interesting to me so let's get more into
this mechanic and one of the things you
could do
yeah so uh in this tutorial you have a
commander and he's just controlled by
the computer right now you're just
controlling this one mac so you can
click on them
and then you click on that little blue
arrow
and that'll let you run you can go to
that circle there and then you hit
execute
execute down
yeah yeah so
uh what will be revealed in a couple
turns is our timeline okay and the whole
thing with phantom brigade is you have a
five second timeline and they have this
technology that lets them see five
seconds into the future so you can plan
everything around those five seconds
and of course uh
the five seconds are what you intend to
do and what the enemy intends to do okay
but reality is not always going to go
out like that so like you shoot someone
and their legs get shot out for example
they're going to stop going in the way
that they were going they're not going
to be at that point where they
originally planned to be
same goes if you crash into someone both
of those things aren't going to be where
they intended to be
yeah yeah that's pretty much it so it is
um
when it comes to combat is it one of
those things where
is there any form of like overwatch
where someone shoots when they move
because if they're both if both parties
are moving together i find that like the
combat might be a little like clunky
because you can't really
move everyone and shoot at the same time
it's like one of those things we want to
shoot after you see them once they're
already on the field or is there any
kind of abilities where they start
shooting the moment they come on
on the screen um it might be a little
bit easier to show you rather than tell
you so this is going to boot up the
timeline right here so you finally get
access to the full timeline
and right now this is kind of
pre-pre-war
so the pre-invasion
they don't really know what's going on
they think that the civilians have maybe
messed with this communications tower
and we're about to find out that no it
was an actual enemy and they're starting
their invasion here okay uh so what
you'll want to do yeah just run to the
circle again
yeah so if you when you scrub the
timeline that's you can see
got it okay got it yeah so like if
you've edited videos and stuff this
should be a little more
like
yeah
yeah we kind of call it our little video
editor as well
nice so now we finally get an enemy here
to see
and keep in mind it's fully voiced too
really i love fully voice i love that it
gives it so much more depth to your
characters and your people and
personality because let's be honest text
is great but
you know i'd like to get more engaged
into the the narrative and the storyline
oh yeah we do have a bunch of narrative
events kind of like stellar style uh so
those aren't voiced but uh yeah so when
you scrub through it you can see uh the
enemy's movements and when you see that
cone that is the enemy firing on you
this bright red the solid red if you go
back a little bit
oh yeah
the solid red that is the his ideal
firing range right and when it gets
choppy it'll probably still hit you but
it'll be less accurate like a spray yes
so pretty much
next turn this individual tank cannot
pass this yeah that's as far as you can
as long as you keep this unit out of
that range you'll be fine yeah so you're
not controlling this one right now
that's the ai you're right now right
there
so what you'll probably want to do is
you'll want to shoot that tank as soon
as possible so that your commander
doesn't take as much damage
so that little donut that you see like
this big ring around you that's your
ideal firing range right so you can move
um and try to keep the enemy within that
ideal firing range as you move and then
at the same time keep yourself out of
their firing range is there is there a
friendly fire like can you be shooting
at someone oh there's definitely
friendly fire you can make the enemy
friendly fire each other as well and as
well the terrain is all fully
destructible there'll be buildings
houses if you run through the trees
they'll fall over
so just to clarify like
it's kind of like
like here's the whole turn everything's
gonna happen in this turn so for
instance i would be better to move
closer because it looks like this is the
whole attack duration and if i was
closer i would shoot him more before
well so if you uh
do your movements uh so get your blue
movement here and try to go back so see
this this is your ideal firing range and
what you want to do is you want to keep
him in there so if you get too close
if the enemy is within this here that's
going to be too close you're not going
to do as much damage
yeah so what you're going to want to do
is
like get as much of this red line and
this firing range is false okay so the
red line is his his uh
his attack
yeah the red line is his attack so
you're seeing his movement you see he's
moving his attack yeah
and basically as that comb yeah
yep
so you can see here
so you got them
also it can't
it considers the movement of the
shooting as well
yeah so you can see where they're gonna
aim where they're going to move
and all that stuff gotcha now the um
the next themselves
are like figures in for taking out a leg
now or each of the enemies
quadrant base like you could take on
torso leg arm things like that right
yeah and like that would also work for
like a tank you want to take out like
one shredder yeah the tanks have some
treads the mechs have a torso legs right
arm left arm okay and if they have a
shield that will also count the shield
gotcha uh and they're all all your mechs
are fully customizable too so you can
change out their armor you can change
out their weapons we have melee weapons
we have energy beam weapons we have
snipers shotguns nice so there's all
that stuff now let's say you get further
in the game what's the max amount of
match you can have the screen on you can
have four so you control four but the
enemy can have a ton so
okay
a little clearer
so pretty much like if i were playing a
regular game and i had two
i would be able to control him see his
movements and see yes so once we
complete this tutorial we'll actually go
into something control two of the same
time
so that's that's it for the tutorial
here
um there's going to be a little cut
scene and then we'll launch into the
next part
yeah so it's kind of like a looting game
as well after all of your battles
there'll be like a salvage okay
so you have a yeah you have a certain
number of uh things you can salvage you
have to choose what you want to take um
which also means like if you fully
destroy an enemy right
they
uh there's gonna be less things to
salvage
so what you can do is disable it you can
try to disable it there's a whole bunch
of different kinds of damage types
so like there's concussion so if you can
cuss a pilot they'll be knocked out and
you can save most of their mech or their
tank impressive attack yeah but also if
you start
um if you do enough damage to an enemy
they'll eject
so you can yeah almost like a titanfall
okay
so is this like a linear story where it
goes for one kind of thing but otherwise
they're an over world that continues
into these missions there's an overworld
you know this you know
yeah and this is gonna have uh like
multi-player against other people
eventually or not really it's the same
kind of answers
yeah so you know there's a lot of
potential to manifest something there is
really intense multiplayer yeah so as
you can see you now have a bunch more
actions yes uh and you also have two
different mechs
you can inject your pilot if you want to
right now so are the pilots individual
from the actual people and they have
their own stats and you know that's why
you want to save them
yes so uh we're still working on our
full pilot system right now there's
mainly just a fatigue system so they can
get tired okay um
but like your pilots are valuable and so
if you uh if one dies you have to go and
recruit another one and that can be kind
of tough
let me ask you you said this fatigue
system like
if they're tired
then how does this affect the gameplay
luke is it something where they just
won't be able to operate the neck or
like what happens um it'll be it they i
think they um don't shoot as as uh well
i i actually need to double check on
that of course but yeah we're reworking
a lot of how it currently works gotcha
now do you not want to like destroy the
buildings in the area like for like
those holes and things like that or does
it not matter do like i don't know what
the uh the thought process is like are
you supposed to be defending oh god like
you're like you know your home is here
or technically you're supposed to be
defending
but uh
everyone's kind of evacuated from it and
it's so cool when you can just ram
through the building
i mean look if there's transition
yeah somebody's house might just be in
the middle of this gunfight you know i
mean in all seriousness we we do
understand that like this is a very
serious topic there's a lot of things
going on in the world right now
um and we want to tackle these topics
with as much care as possible and that's
one of the reasons why we want to
encourage people to like let the enemy
eject so like we don't want people to
commit war crimes even if it's in a game
right fair enough so we encourage mercy
is is the is the deal fair enough now
the unit a lot of units on the screen
now it's getting intense yeah getting
surrounded attitudes
selecting our targets yeah
all right let's see how that's gonna
play out and moving so you can probably
already tell this mech here is a much
lighter frame so we can travel farther
right i mean his weapons are more
mid-range so you stay a little bit
farther back the other mech oh so first
of all when you see this yellow sphere
that means there's a collision
so you don't want to you don't want to
do that unless you're doing it on
purpose you can shield bash people
so is there a quick way to switch back
and forth between the units i think you
can do it with zero and or f
i think zero or one
no f1 f2 oh yeah
awesome awesome
all right so now we're still planning
we're still playing our strategy
you're gonna leave that alone at it
you're not gonna mess with that
setting up right now setting up
yeah so let's see
what's going on here
looking at the time placement
yeah you've made a couple waypoints so
you're doing like a little bit of a
loop-de-loop here
um
and you're running into your other mech
right now is there a way to like go back
you can cancel your things by right
double right clicking
oh yeah oh
okay so that's how you retract those
actions yeah okay got it
yeah so this is a heavier so they're
they're they have a lot more
they're able to tank a lot more but they
want to get closer with the shotgun and
also you can put up a shield to block a
lot of damage and i've noticed it has a
percentage right so when you shoot
something
okay because obviously shotgun the
closer you are the more damage you're
going to do
but i like that because
games like xcom they they give you a
percentage it doesn't make sense
this lets you set up your percentage
yeah i know there's a lot of games where
like there's the percentage and so like
if it doesn't fall in the percentage you
just totally miss all your damage right
uh in this game all the bullets are
actually individually simulated so
you're going to do damage no matter what
it's just a matter of how much it is so
almost in a sense it's a guaranteed hit
but the amount of damage moving sort of
guarantees
the movements uh
so like if
there's missiles in the game for example
if you're shooting missiles at an enemy
tank
um and they dash out of the way or vice
versa um then those will probably not
hit you gotcha but like if you're just
walking and there's no uh unexpected
things happening you're probably gonna
hit it gotcha
got it got it so as you can see yeah
that's that's basically what happened
actually
now that i've always seen it seem to be
against you
the odds are always again yeah so again
what are some things that we could do to
kind of like bolster
you know our defenses
on strategy that we could employ because
it looks like right now attic is
surrounded there's a lot going on right
now this one in particular so we a lot
of people actually find this very first
one uh to be pretty difficult yeah um
and that's because you are pretty
outnumbered and you're still kind of
learning the timeline right um but
eventually as you play more you're able
to get better weapons better armor uh so
that you're higher level against the
enemies um and also just like
personally the way that i like to
strategize is i like to make sure that
all my mix just kind of focused fire
something so you take things out one by
one very quickly instead of spreading
out because there's way more of them
than you all the time right
absolutely what's your plan what what's
the plan of attack
i'm just still trying to figure out how
to work some of it
what's uh if you have any questions i'm
happy to how do i just basically shoot
people because
i know this thing is like when i do
something it doesn't always show up yes
so it is a little i it's not a super
intuitive but what you have to do is you
have to place it on the timeline first
so if you do you do your run on the map
but then the other abilities work a
little bit differently so if you want to
get a little bit closer or somewhere
within your donut range
a little bit closer probably to the
enemy a little bit more there perfect um
and then to your shooting
and you put it on the timeline first oh
so that's when you start shooting and
then after you place on the timeline
then you can select the target so you
you can literally see it right after you
run yeah yeah wall runner you can shoot
while running oh no you can fly
yeah you can put as many things on the
timeline as you want
but there is an overheat mechanic so if
you do too many things your mech is
going to overheat and take damages oh
wow
so that's kind of our way of controlling
balance and control yeah we can run over
here
they're all shooting at you yeah
everybody's going down i'm about to get
the word yeah
yeah at this point
you can also choose to like wait for
them to finish firing so you have the
undercover right and then you can move
yeah see you got one already nice you're
good
um the mech did flank you there yes
i think you'll be fine
i mean extraction is something that we
have in the game to use if you find
yourself in a situation that isn't quite
winnable you can go there's like a
little square highlighted on the map if
you go there you can extract your units
and get out of there with what you've
managed to get now overall like again
with something like an extraction phase
like what would what would be the
long-term ramification let's say for
example you extract a lot on missions
like is it
going to affect the overall uh world
layer like what does it affect so it's
usually uh a lot of the missions are you
have to eliminate the enemy right so if
you retreat you just don't complete the
mission
and the whole point of the overworld is
uh you're trying to raise the hope of
all the citizens in all the different
provinces okay so if you don't
complete what you're intending to do
your hope doesn't get raised and you're
not unable to take the provinces back
gotcha gotcha and i'm starting to get it
now yeah once you once you understand
timeline first then target it's a lot
it's a lot easier but it does take a
little bit of getting used to because no
other game really does no the game
doesn't that's okay so that's where the
learning curve is in complete sense yeah
you have to take in consideration where
he's going to be and you have to make
sure that your other person is going to
get hit yeah imagine when you have four
mechs to consider
cool but it's so fun you have like one
light mech with the sniper who's able to
get around and like reposition you have
one mech who has a sword and just going
in there slashing all the enemies uh so
there's a whole bunch of different
things how do i start this
uh you just hit execute yeah and so what
you can do is you hit spacebar
and it goes the slo-mo
yeah and you can close it
oh yeah yeah you can zoom in too with
the scroll bar oh and you pitched with r
and f so you can
see yeah so it's really cinematic as you
so that's that's the whole point i made
rula cool
okay there we go
yeah so you see you've got that
concussion damage
if you get it to 100 the pilot's knocked
out got it
they also get me actually i like that i
like it
or something right now that's not
implemented that's something not really
implemented right now uh it's something
that we've talked about you know like
having specific mech commanders in the
enemy that are uh
rivals and like they get stronger as you
get stronger
right now the end goal is you want to
retake the capital so that's kind of the
boss fight gotcha okay um yeah so out of
curiosity is there
different versions of
like is there a melee for that mag
cyclomax yeah so there's it's not
dependent on the mech itself but on the
weapon you choose so you can re-kit any
of your mix to whatever you want it to
be eventually so you pretty much choose
how you want your background yes you got
it yeah actually after this
yeah let's see what we can do here
um you can click on your two little
mechs in the uh so on your timeline here
right
yeah so that that's the one that doesn't
have orders gotcha oh and he's the one
that is fast yeah
just be careful about friendly fire on
your own mech
make sure you click select your target
yeah
there you go
see if we can get through this
all right here we go we're playing it
out
[Music]
they're gonna just limp around but yeah
so what i can do right now is i can give
you a quick show of the over world yes
let's do that
um
i kind of figured out how to overwhelm
yeah you you knew exactly what was
coming
you'll see this
that's where you can like research my
parts and stuff like that so yeah
so
we'll pause right now because this is
happens in real time uh you have your
mobile base so the whole thing is you
have this mobile base with all your
mechs you have to roam around trying
with your very small team to reclaim
territory
so you can click up there go through
that you can go into your base so
you have your little neck here that was
cool wow that looks really cool yeah and
so from here you can also customize
uh your mechs uh oh you actually need to
go back to the overworld real quick
because they're repairing so if you hit
play so you can see them repairing there
ah gotcha and then once they finish
repairing you can go there
i mean i did send one to a sea side
yeah and then you can do edit
and so here you can see you can edit all
these different things and normally you
have way more parts as you get going
different levels different guns
so like with me like melee people you
can you know go with tank builds if you
want to try like you just mix match how
you want to play the game yeah yeah
that's pretty cool exactly and then you
can also change all their colors too so
there's a whole i love that yeah that
customization personalize it making it
back yours yeah yeah very very cool and
also the overall mechanic because i do
like the now i'm getting the sense of
what you're talking about which is
liberating the world getting things back
under control yeah it's a lot a lot of
potential here we're definitely feeling
that you can see in the one on if you go
to the right or the that one there's a
workshop so you can craft different
weapons and body types and then you can
upgrade your mobile base there so
there's a whole bunch of there you go
[Music]
right now so
it is highly requested yes yes we could
totally see it look we're really excited
about it phantom degrade again early
access right early access on the epic
game star right now nice nice and again
i will say this this is another thing as
a fan of turn base i know i know your
early access but our console brethren
would love
this love yes yes
well we're looking forward to it and
again
can they find more information about it
besides early access so our website
braceyourselfgames.com we're on discord
discord dot com slash race yourself
games we also have twitter's um and like
a newsletter you can find all that on
our website though nice and absolute
pleasure it was so nice so guys the
lords vanderbilt checking it out very
cool very unique mechanic in terms of
the turn base and going at the same time
in a different strategy later check it
out
[Music]
you